well nurses will strike from 8pm this
evening until 11 59 on Monday night
unite ambulance workers will walk out
the following day immediately after the
bank holiday the Royal College of
Nursing promised there are measures in
place to provide critical care for
neonatal and Pediatric Intensive units
members will also leave the picket line
to provide what's described as life and
limb cover in intensive care and for an
accident in emergency departments as
Paul kelser now reports
Mario could qualified as a psychiatric
nurse just three years ago but despite
rapid promotion her basic take-home pay
is 1700 pounds a month and she has to
work up to 60 hours a week just to make
ends meet
when you come you work 12 and a half
hours to sit in here
and you have to think can I buy food
electricity or food in a car
the basic things is embarrassing so
you're living on your own your children
are grown up but you still have to work
a 60-hour week just talk to me or just
explain that to me yes I do because
otherwise I don't have money to pay for
my rent my council tax and top of this I
had to pay my student loan back the cost
of living squeeze is a major driver of
strike action by nurses a 28-hour
walkout by members of the Royal College
of Nursing that employers say may be the
most disruptive yet with only life and
limb care guaranteed over the bank
holiday following negotiations with the
Union I accepted
strike that services do not have the
same level of nursing staff there are
National exemptions in place for a range
of services for emergency departments
for intensive care units for neonatal
units Pediatric Intensive Care units
those really acute urgent services
the NHS staff Council comprising all
Health unions meets on Tuesday and is
expected to accept a five percent pay
offer a below inflation settlement the
health secretary says is fair the staff
council is due to meet on Tuesday I'm
cautiously optimistic that the the staff
Council will agree to then vote in favor
of the deal but I think it's right to
wait until Tuesday for the staff Council
to meet and this strike is premature for
patients like Ron waiting for a lung
transplant for 20 months and his wife
Maxine the prospect of strikes affecting
intensive care brings another worry in
the daily weight the news I've waited 20
months for a very serious operation and
maybe with the strikes I don't know
whether I'll lose that chance to get my
transplant which is a life-saving
transplant because at the end of the day
my deterioration is worsening I could
lose that one opportunity I'll never
know but it that may be the case if he
has to go to hospital it's
you know really get the treatment he
needs so yeah I should be glad when it's
over and then I will fall a bit a lot
more relaxed
the LCN says it will ballot its members
on further strike action the result will
reveal whether a Long Winter has
exhausted the appetite for dispute Paul
Kelso Sky News